a year of war in Yemen has killed more
than 6,000 people and displaced millions
more after Houthi rebels backed by Iran
to the capital city Sanaa a coalition of
Arab countries led by Saudi Arabia began
a military campaign to restore the
deposed government and behind the scenes
the US has played a big role in 2015 the
u.s. sold more than 21 billion dollars
worth of weapons to the two countries
most involved in the war Saudi Arabia
and the UAE those sales included cluster
bombs which are banned by over a hundred
countries the impact of those arms has
been devastating with 60% of casualties
caused by airstrikes alone a single
coalition attack on a busy marketplace
in haja province killed a hundred and
six people including 24 children the UN
says schools hospitals and civilian
infrastructure have also been hit
the White House says it's set up a joint
planning cell with a Saudi military to
help coordinate the war while American
soldiers aren't directly involved in the
fighting the u.s. air force's run
mid-air refueling missions for coalition
jets they've also provided surveillance
intelligence and other data to help
coordinate airstrikes but Human Rights
Watch says that densely populated areas
have still been targeted the u.s.
support for the coalition campaign is
unlimited to the military side when the
UN proposed an independent investigation
into possible war crimes in Yemen the US
backed a counter proposal to have the
investigation carried out by the
coalition's ally the Yemeni government
now even before the war Yemen was the
poorest country in the region but the
fighting has made water food and fuel
shortages so much worse and despite the
u.s. role in all of this virtually no
one is paying attention at home
presidential candidates have barely
commented on a war they might inherit
but there may be a glimmer of hope on
the horizon a ceasefire is scheduled to
begin on April 10th meanwhile it's
Yemen's civilians who continue to suffer
with 80% of the population now in need
of humanitarian aid
[Music]